an investigation is underway into the
death of an Indiana toddler who fell
from a Royal Caribbean cruise ship in
Puerto Rico it appears to have been a
tragic accident the one-year-old girl's
grandfather apparently lost his grip
while holding her near a window on the
ship Don Dahler reports on what we're
learning Porto Ricans safety officials
tell a local newspaper that detectives
are gathering evidence and trying to
determine whether to file negligence
charges against an Indiana man after his
one year old granddaughter fell to her
death on board a Royal Caribbean cruise
ship docked in San Juan the grandfather
has been identified as Salvatore anello
an IT worker in South Bend Indiana
people loved him here in the county an
Ellis boss told CBS affiliate WSB T he
is a model employee
he's a very selfless man he's got a
servant's heart as we say and just one
of the most wonderful human beings you
could ever meet the toddler was on board
the ship with her two siblings parents
and four grandparents the South Bend
Indiana Police Department says one of
its officers Alan Wiegand is the child's
father in a statement the department
said it offers its sincerest condolences
to the officer and ask the community to
pray for the family falling off a cruise
ship is very rare it's estimated that
over 28 million people went on a cruise
last year according to a website that
tracks people falling off of them since
2000 only around 340 people have gone
overboard for CBS this morning
I'm Don Dahler that family really that
is one of the worst stories I've heard I
really hope they don't charge negligent
charges imagine he's already feeling
here feeling the worst it's already
feeling terrible and in pain you could
feel this one you wonder what he was
thinking and why he did it but it's been
done it's a terrible terrible thing it's
now the family has to figure out a way
to get through this I hope he's not
charged and everybody knows him says
he's a really good guy clearly just a
big lapse of judgment there I agree I
agree